[Música]
[Aplausos]
Bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
de France 24 que los invita a dar una
vuelta al mundo de la mano de nuestra
red de periodistas las operaciones de
búsqueda y rescate llegaron a su fin en
la ciudad de Nitro allí un misil
atribuido a las tropas rusas provocó el
colapso de un edificio Residencial en el
que murieron al menos 44 civiles
incluyendo cinco niños escenas ya
habituales en Ucrania en medio de
oleadas constantes de ataques por parte
de Moscú a pesar de que los rusos
nieguen tomar a la población ucraniana
como objetivo ante la enorme cantidad de
artillería rusa las autoridades
ucranianas han convertido en una
prioridad la apertura de casos por
crímenes de guerra en contra de Moscú
por eso recogen catalogan y examinan
cuidadosamente todos los restos de
misiles guiados balísticos y de crucero
que caen en múltiples zonas del país
nuestros corresponsales
tuvieron acceso a uno de los varios
lugares donde se recopilan estas
evidencias en la región de jarquín
filas y filas de cohetes y misiles y
bombas son los restos de los ataques
rusos en Ucrania
los de aquí solo en la ciudad de harqui
dejan un tesoro de información sensible
para los ucranianos
tenemos que ser extremadamente
cuidadosos con lo que filmamos ya que lo
que nos han dicho es que Rusia tiende a
tratar de apuntar A las pruebas dejadas
Atrás de su agresión en Ucrania ya sean
los cuerpos de sus propios muertos en la
guerra para Ocultar sus pérdidas o
restos de misiles como este que los
ucranianos quieren utilizar para
construir casos de crímenes de guerra
recuperamos información como
abreviaciones símbolos y cifras que los
especialistas militares pueden decretar
esto nos permite determinar la fábrica
en la que el misil fue producido
y saber a qué unidad militar ha sido
proporcionado
Los investigadores relacionan los restos
con ataques específicos y sus víctimas
como base de pruebas en un futuro caso
judicial un análisis más detallado
también puede decir a los ucranianos si
Moscú será capaz de mantener los
repetidos ataques con misiles o no
la cantidad de estos que tiene Rusia
está disminuyendo rápidamente Rusia
necesita producirlos ya han alcanzado un
nivel crítico de reservas de estos
cohetes incluso para la defensa de su
propio país si alguna otra nación
intenta invadirles
una repentina sirena de ataque aéreo
parece indicar que Rusia por ahora
mantiene su táctica
[Música]
están mejorando nuestra posición para
reunir más pruebas con cada ataque creen
que nos hacen daño pero se hacen daño a
sí mismos
en última instancia los restos aquí
podrían desecharse cuando ya no se
necesiten aunque los investigadores nos
dijeron que les gustaría verlos en un
museo con los más de miles que hay en
este lugar uno de los varios que existen
en la región de harkins valorados en
unos 100 millones de dólares al menos
antes de ser utilizados sería toda una
exposición
según el nuevo estudio publicado en la
revista Science Epson Mobile una de las
mayores petroleras del mundo predijo que
el cambio climático provocaría un
aumento de la temperatura global ya en
la década de 1970 según documentos
internos de la empresa que fueron
analizados por expertos exon había
generado modelos de alta calidad sobre
los impactos de la quema de combustible
fósiles en el calentamiento del planeta
al tiempo impulsaba campañas de
desinformación y propaganda con el fin
de retrasar la acción climática informe
de
el secreto de exxon móvil al descubierto
de acuerdo a un nuevo estudio la
petrolera predijo con exactitud del
calentamiento global a pesar de poner en
duda la crisis climática durante años
Naomi es una de las académicas que
analizó los datos de los documentos
internos de la empresa
en 1988 reconocieron que se trataba de
un problema muy grave
Así que claramente Aquí está en blanco y
negro saben cuál es el problema y saben
lo que están causando sus productos
la investigación Privada de Epson decía
el efecto invernadero puede ser uno de
los problemas más importantes de la
década de 1990 otro elemento clave de la
investigación este gráfico de los años
70 que predecía con exactitud una curva
ascendente de las temperaturas globales
y las emisiones de dióxido de carbono en
los últimos años estados ciudades y
condados de Estados Unidos han
presentado decenas de demandas
judiciales acusando a Epson de engaño
público y exigiendo miles de millones de
dólares por daños climáticos esta nueva
investigación podría aportar más pruebas
a esos casos a medida que avanzan en los
tribunales sin embargo exon móvil
negando cualquier delito esta cuestión
ha surgido varias veces en los últimos
años y en cada caso nuestra respuesta es
la misma quienes hablan de que éxon lo
sabía se equivocan en sus conclusiones
en los últimos años otras empresas de
combustibles fósiles también han sido
objeto de críticas por restar
importancia a la amenaza del cambio
climático
continúan las manifestaciones en Perú
especialmente en Lima y en el sur del
país donde se han registrado múltiples
bloqueos de carreteras ministros del
gobierno de Dina boluarte han renunciado
a sus cargos en protesta por la cerca de
50 muertes que se han producido en el
marco de la peor ola de violencia
desatada en el país en 20 años tras la
destitución del entonces presidente
Pedro Castillo la mandataria Dina
boluarte ha pedido disculpas pero
también ha dejado en claro que no
pretende renunciar a su cargo algo que
exigen miles de manifestantes en las
calles nuestros corresponsales Juliette
tienen el siguiente reportaje desde
cusco
en la turística ciudad de cusco crece el
movimiento de protesta los trabajadores
han declarado una huelga por tiempo
indeterminado llevan semanas en la calle
con las mismas reivindicaciones que
dimita la nueva presidenta Dina boluarte
que se disuelva el congreso y se convoca
en elecciones anticipadas
algunos están tres días dos días cinco
días están vienen dejando a sus hijos
vienen acá a Ciudad a luchar
las calles de la ciudad están bloqueadas
Nadie puede pasar salvo la gente del
campo que viene a manifestar a pesar del
caos boluarte se ha negado a dimitir
de la derecha Por ende nuestro voto
tiene que ser respetado la gente el
pueblo en general han votado para Pedro
Castillo no padinna boluarte
las comunidades rurales están
especialmente enfadadas se sienten
ignorados y frustrados por la falta de
apoyo estatal en educación y salud pero
más no se acuerdan del pueblo del pueblo
andino que somos nosotros quienes
trabajamos por ellos no también Mira
justamente nuestra nuestro turismo todo
se va a ellos nuestra agricultura se va
a ellos las manifestaciones se han
vuelto violentas en algunas ocasiones en
el último mes más de 40 personas han
muerto en enfrentamientos con las
fuerzas de seguridad y cientos más han
resultado heridas no es posible que
sigamos permitiendo estas muertes y
también tantos heridos que tenemos en el
hospital por eso el pueblo realmente
estamos amargados
durante las protestas del miércoles en
cusco un líder de la comunidad llamado
Remo candia fue asesinado un millar de
personas marcharon por las calles de la
ciudad para rendir homenaje por Levantar
la voz que nos maten no es justo porque
en realidad mujer o varón o niño tenemos
todo el derecho de hablar porque acá los
compañeros ninguno somos terroristas no
somos asesinos somos campesinos Entonces
yo no entiendo de las personas porque
nos mandan a los policías que también
son nuestros hermanos nos ponen a
matarnos con la misma gente
varios grupos de derechos humanos han
condenado la violencia y han hecho un
llamado al diálogo
en Italia desde el inicio de la pandemia
la delincuencia juvenil está aumentando
en el último año los arrestos de menores
subieron más de un 10% un fenómeno que
tiene preocupadas a las autoridades
locales el gobierno italiano ha
anunciado recientemente un proyecto de
decreto para impedir las congregaciones
de menores en algunas zonas específicas
determinadas por la policía prohibiendo
también el uso de teléfonos celulares a
menores sospechosos de haber participado
en actividades criminales el objetivo es
desmantelar estas llamadas baby gangs
cuyos miembros a veces tienen tan solo
12 años de edad nos cuentan más nuestras
corresponsales Natalia Mendoza lorenza
pensa y Luis Manuel
grupos de jóvenes Ultra violentos se
enfrentan o asaltan comercios a mano
armada en Italia se les conoce como los
baby gangs su particularidad sus
miembros son menores de edad
un fenómeno en aumento en la periferia
de Milán esta noche los carabineros
controlan una de las zonas más sensibles
de la ciudad
estamos apostando vamos en camino a
lugares habitualmente frecuentados por
miembros de Baby gangs es una zona en
donde se encuentran en las noches
en este barrio se han registrado
denuncias por robos y asaltos cometidos
por Menores en los últimos meses son ya
las diez de la noche nuestra cámara
atrae la atención de este niño
[Música]
esta noche ningún delito salta a la
vista de los agentes el trabajo de
investigación prosigue en el cuartel a
través del análisis de las redes
sociales en donde los jóvenes
delincuentes exhiben sus acciones
criminales
es el uso de las redes sociales y la
espectacularización de la violencia
quieren ganar seguidores y conquistar
popularidad en los principales canales
sociales y principal
El procurador del tribunal de menores de
Milán ha seguido de cerca la evolución
de fenómeno criminal que se ha agudizado
en los últimos meses durante la pandemia
durante la pandemia muchos jóvenes
empezaron a acumular rabia y frustración
es algo que no logran contener Y que
ahora explota no se logran desfogar de
otra manera
diversamente para los menores de edad
del sistema judicial italiano Busca
apenas alternativas a la cárcel en
comunidades educativas como esta Aquí
viven unos 50 jóvenes enviados por el
tribunal de menores de Milán
hacer asaltos a los 14 años habían
noches en las que hacía unos 40 o 50
saltos también hacía extorsiones ganaba
dinero fácil me arrestaron en flagrancia
Tratamos de hacerles entender sus
errores que comprendan porque han
cometido delitos y sobre todo tratamos
que se proyecten en construir un futuro
de diferente
un futuro diferente para estos jóvenes
lejos de la criminalidad
Muchas gracias por seguir un nuevo
episodio de corresponsales nos damos
cita la próxima semana siga con más
información en France 24 y France 24.com